What's up everyone?
Welcome to a new vlog.
I'm in Iceland with Marzia and two gnomes.
So, the plan is to recreate
my last Iceland vlog.
Footage by footage, step by step.
PJ you just ruined my shot.
(PJ) I know I did. (Felix)
Oh my god, Marzia!
(PJ) I enhanced your shot.
You made it worse! (PJ) I made it better-
I'm gonna photoshop you away.
(PJ) That's impossible.
They're not playing the organ.
I'll pay you 500.
If you play it -inaudible-.
(Felix) Marzia do it.
That was really good.
This is why I am here. I am here for the fish soup.
We ate here last time.
We're recreating everything, basically.
(Felix) The fish soup. (PJ) We got it.
Jesus Christ!
Are you okay -inaudible-?
So, the water is... steaming...?
Which must mean that it's hot.
It is!
Oh my god!
Touch it!
It's really nice!
i am so exited
there is... oh yeah!
this is what i'm talking about:
one food i miss from sweden
is the fish soup
so all one
mm
thats good
another think i love about iceland
is the had the same sweets as in sweden
all this stuff i have miss
very nice
thats the end of day one
i know that was practice nothing
but
we have a long day tomorrow so
we have time to futige tham.
wee you tomorrow
daaaaam!
look it that!
we got snow boys
we gonna me driving the golden cycle day so
that shut be interesting
showing so much
got dam
Swedish man impressed by snow
here i'm living in UK
don't judge me
you trying. what do you doing?
and explain this
oh!
ah!
kill you
no!
oh
i have skills bich
it's valentines day
i remember but iam home a year ago
it's gonna died!
we are right a first stop at the golden cycle
it's a lake
oh my god!
oh god im scared
so pretty
why do comae no out?
what are you doing?
i'm pushingin the tgay
oh my god it´s hot!
there you can swim
or drink it right now!
there look it all is. oh i smell this
god dam it smell
come on guy there is living the moment
what are you kidding me?
got dam it
nice
wow
god dam it!
that was awsome
wow and the second one!
so next stop is the waterfall
i think its snowing
i both this
very nice
Island flag
cause to night we go to the
wow what a nice view
go to the waterfall
and
god dam it snow
wow holy sh*t
god dam
ive benn her before but i have
it's blue lagoon time every one
very exiting
here we go!
whreting the stinky
blue
oh god the wind
do look it that, so pretty
you see the moon, you see the stars
amazing
we swim in true
very nice
i look crazy
we back in the lagoon
how is this?
amazong
I just
shared it
wow you merry me what i saw
Happy Valentines day
i really hate maskt
oh god dam!
that is not a good look
oh my good it's mr.
the clown
wow fake friend
oh its snowing and it's hitting my face so hard
so got the crap
oh jeah, oh jeah oh god it's so cold but
very crappie
we walking  back
successfully  think about blue lagoons once
se you tonmorow bye!
so we are driving 8 houres
i dont now where we are but it's very
very pretty i had another fish soup
very nice
and we are going to closed destanation
you can't good see because it's foog about the mountains
everything is so pretty and the ocean is this right there
and also more importantly
i prepare the snowballs
tha whan p s cames out
he is gonna get it!
look it that!
whats up horses?
you got great shots over here
cool we got the horses we good to go sky driving
this road is crazy
oh tis smeel tham or you p jey
look it this. You cant see the street it's white everywhere
god dam
we have a rime
in the middle of no where
and it`s snowing
i dont know what this be on it
it'a a guy
it's a giant snow man
of 1000 year a good luck
oh my good
iam back in sweden
it's accetly ice here
like down there
so we ... walk down
it's gonna be pretty cold and snowi but
wow look at this rocks
wow this caves in there
lets trash is